paying a fee to check luggage has become
a routine part of air travel but it
wasn't always this way
in the United States baggage fees
started in 2008 right around the time
oil prices were peaking another day
another dollar crude oil broke another
record we're gonna go from a profitable
year in oh seven to ten billion dollar
loss Inouye and the only thing that has
changed is fuel jet fuel prices have
been taking drastic measures including a
15 dollar charge for the first check bag
fifteen dollars holy cow I'll have to
put my underwear in my pocket to avoid
the new fees passengers started cramming
everything into their carry-ons but two
years ago fuel prices dropped and they
stayed low ever since the fees however
haven't gone anywhere
the only exception among major carriers
is Southwest Airlines which is famous
for their bags fly free marketing
campaign to make money lots of money
last year revenue from baggage fees was
nearly four billion dollars and the 7.5
percent excise tax that airlines have to
pay on ticket prices doesn't apply to
baggage fees so the tax code actually
encourages the use of fees and they
haven't stopped it check back with
carry-on space now increasingly scarce
airlines can charge a fee to board early
so you can claim spots in the overhead
bin revenue from the fees combined with
other factors like major mergers have
been higher profits for airlines but
what's good for the airlines has not
benefited consumers airlines haven't
lowered air fares in proportion to
higher profits the planes are filling up
anyways so they don't need to compete on
fares and all those carry-on bags are
contributing to longer lines at airport
security this summer passengers were
stuck at two three and even four hour
lines at airports across the country in
response a group of senators in the head
of Homeland Security ask the airlines to
waive baggage fees we've asked their
lives to consider possibly eliminating
the checked baggage fee there's been an
increase in the carry ons due to these
fees so isn't it time to get rid of
baggage fees well there's more to this
story a recent study has revealed a
major benefit to can
tumors that came from baggage fees
better on-time performance for all
airlines according to research done by a
group of Business School professors
charging fees to check two bags
decreases the average departure delay by
two minutes what they found is that the
increase and luggage above the cabin has
not offset the reduction below the cabin
although it seems like carry-ons make
the boarding process longer down on the
ground the airlines are handling fewer
bags when you carry your own bags
between connecting flights that's work
they don't have to do and it seems to be
saving time overall that means fewer
flight delays and fewer missed
connections there's also been a decline
in the number of lost bags so when it
comes to baggage fees it's not all bad
for airline consumers it's just mostly
bad
you
you